let's talk about the number one most
common sign
of low stomach acid indigestion
indigestion what is that indigestion is
a sensation where the food is kind of
stuck in your stomach it's not
moving properly you feel full bloated
you've got an upset stomach some
heartburn
you feel nauseous might be belching so
that's what indigestion is
and of course there are other symptoms
of low stomach acid too
especially getting gas and just general
bloating
now if you look this up medically it'll
say that 70 of the time
there's no cause okay there's no cause
you just have it it could be coming from
stress
anxiety or gerd which doesn't make sense
to me because
gerd is a symptom and that's where you
have acid splashing up so what they're
saying is acid that splashes up
will cause indigestion so one symptom
causes something else i guess it could
be related but as far as a root cause
i don't buy that but i can see stress
being one big cause for sure
and there are many other causes as well
i've done videos on them i'll put a link
down below
the medical term for low stomach acid is
called
hypochlorhydria and there's another
condition where you don't have any acid
in your stomach that's called
a chlorhydria and you can check out more
information on that but this topic is
very important simply because
as you age you lose your stomach acid
and so many people
just don't have enough acid in the
stomach anymore and they're getting
these symptoms and i don't even know
what's behind it and so they start
taking
antacids they take medication for this
and now they go from bad to
worse because now it's going to take out
that last drop that they needed
and now they don't have very much acid
at all so they start developing
hay fever allergies and sinus issues and
all sorts of problems normally the ph of
hydrochloric
acid should be between 0.8 to 1.5
and it can even go up to 3. so it's
between
0.8 0.823 which is extremely acid
and it's a combination of this acid and
this enzyme
pepsin which by the way is activated by
this acid
to help you digest things so pepsin is a
very
strong enzyme to help you digest
protein what prevents
the acid and this powerful protein
enzyme from
digesting the inside of your stomach is
a very thick
mucous layer and so when this layer
becomes destroyed
that can come from a lack of zinc it
could come from several things
then you start developing ulcers
gastritis and issues like that so we
need this layer of protection
your body actually makes two liters of
hydrochloric acid
every single day and guess what you need
to
to make it you need chlorides from
salt you also need potassium
you need vitamin c and several other
things
like zinc now the purpose of
hydrochloric acid is to take the protein
that you just ate let's say you ate some
meat
which has protein and collagen and all
sorts of things
and turn that into amino acids to break
it down into the small particles
so if you don't have enough acid you'll
get incomplete protein
digestion also number two
it helps you kill microbes bacteria
fungus yeast and
viruses without that acid these microbes
can invade the body and go down there
and create all sorts of
damage and something called sibo
and they can invade your gut and create
problems so it's a defense
mechanism viruses and bacteria do not
like
acid number three they help you absorb
minerals a lot of times
the minerals are locked up with proteins
for example if you ask someone what what
food is high in iron you would say
red meat right or when you talk about
calcium
dairy that comes with a protein right
cobalt is
part of vitamin b12 which is actually in
red meat and organ meats zinc is in
shellfish seafood and red meat as well
and also magnesium is in meat as well
and vegetables
however if you don't have enough acid
you can't separate out
the mineral from this protein structure
not to mention you're going to have a
difficult time
absorbing and assimilating these
minerals right here
and so there's a very simple simple
solution
if you don't have an ulcer or if you
don't have gastritis
it's simply to take some betaine
hydrochloride
you can get this as a supplement i'll
put a link down below for more
information on this but betaine
hydrochloride
is a very simple safe solution
you would want to take something like
three or four or even five with right
before you eat
and you'll start feeling a lot less
indigestion pretty quick
but it might take some time you might
have to do that for several weeks
but you'll find though you'll have less
gas less bloating less fullness
and you'll get more complete digestion
with this and you're going to start to
feel better because you'll start to
assimilate
these minerals right here
now if you have gastritis or an
ulcer or you feel worse when you take
this then you need to watch my video on
what to do with an ulcer or gastritis
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help